fariba savez très bien reconnaître les
signes que son fils aumède n'avait pas
assez à manger
elle est donc venu chercher de l'aide
ici dans cet hôpital public de la
province de parwan avant qu'il ne soit
trop tard pour lui
j'avais une autre enfant avant dit elle
elle aussi a souffert de malnutrition
elle a été hospitalisée ici pendant dix
jours où elle recevait du lait mais
quand on est rentré à la maison elle est
morte nous n'avions rien à cuisiner ou à
manger
demain il rentre à la maison tous les
deux la riba sera armé de rations de
céréales complètes fournie par le
programme alimentaire mondial et d'une
prescription pour mieux s'alimenter des
fruits et légumes du lait tous que
fariba et son mari ne peuvent pas se
payer l'hôpital public de parwan manque
de tout ça personnel soignant n'a pas
reçu de salaires depuis quatre mois les
fournisseurs ont cessé les livraisons
ces ambulances sont cloués sur place et
on limite les admissions au strict
minimum
amorim le principal problème que nous
avons dit il c'est nous n'avons aucune
ressource pour chauffer l'hôpital je
crains quand chauffant pas les chambres
des patients correctement ils vont
rentrer chez eux plutôt que de recevoir
des traitements sur foron
le froid c'est celui qui déjà enveloppe
kaboul qui la nuit envahi ces déplacés
abrités sous des tentes rudimentaires ou
des bouts de tissus trois bambins sont
morts dans ce camp de fortune depuis la
semaine dernière dit cette femme
naïma made in belgium imac ce n'est pas
pour le plaisir et nous sommes venus de
badakhshan ce sont les combats qui nous
ont forcés à quitter mon mari est mort
mes fils sont morts mais beau fils aussi
ici nous sommes en paix mais il n'y a
rien à manger bien à boire que pouvons
nous faire
elle accuse les talibans d'empêcher la
distribution des aides dans les camps
pour les forcer à rentrer dans l'eau
vince c'est hors de question dit elle
le programme alimentaire mondial estime
que 14 millions d'afghans font face à
une insécurité alimentaire aiguë 3
million deux cent mille enfants sont
menacés par la malnutrition sévère pour
un million d'entre eux c'est carrément
la mort qui guette
si la fin est presque tous les afghans
ce n'est pas faute de trouver à manger
au pays les étals des marchés déborde de
toujours de produits mais du jour au
lendemain l'afghanistan se retrouve avec
un taux de chômage qui explose une
inflation qui montent en flèche et une
aide humanitaire qui a soutenu le pays
pendant toutes ces décennies
pratiquement coupé à faire
les afghans qui arrivait à tirer leur
épingle du jeu avec les travaux
journaliers sont réduits à se présenter
dans les centres de distribution du
programme alimentaire mondial pour des
produits de base
les talibans je trouvais du travail tous
les jours dit il mais il n'ya plus rien
dans la construction même pour pousser
un chariot
il est ému de recevoir un peu des deux
de la farine de l'huile et du blé de
quoi nourrir sa famille de 10 pour une
quinzaine de jours mais la viande et les
légumes il faut oublier
la communauté internationale a promis le
déblocage d'une aide pour l'afghanistan
d'un montant de 1,2 milliard de dollars
américains en septembre dernier il sera
administré et distribué directement par
les nations unies
mais ça ne suffira pas pour les
tout-petits trop petits patients de
parwan et au delà
ici marie ève bédard radio-canada parwan